my mom always said one of the reasons so
my parents have been married close to 30
years we i have nine siblings clearly
oh she was saying yes all the time
and that's one of the things she told me
she like i liked him it's awkward right
it's my mom but she was like to make
like i asked her like what are the keys
to like a long healthy marriage and she
said one of the keys like if you don't
want your husband to like step out is to
just always say yes because men have
like a higher sex drive than us okay
that is true but what if like one night
you're just tired and he's like hey babe
let's get it on you just say yeah yeah
so you're just like because that's where
there's like mutual respect factor
though
yeah like you need to know like when's
the time to please your man and do a
thing for him but like vice versa yeah
if you don't want it like that then it
shouldn't be a [ __ ] conversation it
shouldn't be a like it should be no
[ __ ] big yeah yeah
i just want to do that stuff if you're
with someone that has gone through
sexual abuse in their life intimacy is a
lot different it's not just as simple as
let's have sex sometimes you know you
have bad days you have good days so
you need to be with a part of you like
personally i was sexually abused like
with like in
many different facets so like
my partner has to be very understanding
with me yeah so the patient like i have
a friend who's mormon right so i don't
know if your family your mom is
specifically like catholic catholic
i know you were but i don't know like
she's mormon her mom told her the same
thing told her the same thing and she
got into a situation where some things
happened with her man that she
wasn't you know i'm not gonna yeah yeah
yeah but you get what i'm saying it's
like you have to have boundaries for
yourself as a woman like our body is
like
this is ours and it's sacred like if you
don't want it to be touched if you don't
want it right no well it's not but it's
not but it's not in a way like like she
does it because she has to like she
loves my dad
yeah yeah and what about her but that's
the key though is that she's okay with
that if she doesn't feel violated then
it's okay by all means she could do that
as much as she wants
me speaking as somebody who's also been
sexually abused like i've been in that
position where it's like i feel
obligated to please my partner but i'm
not comfortable with it and it's like
they can clearly clearly see the
discomfort in me and not respect that
then you start to wonder if they just
see you as a sexual being if they just
see you as a toy rather than an actual
person that experienced something so
terrible so yeah on the flip side do you
guys think there's ever a point where
it's like it's been too long like
because in my opinion like if you
haven't had sex with your husband in
like two or three years he's going
somewhere
i'm glad you saw my teeth like
like
me
like and i wouldn't even blame them like
i guys have to like do that guys
for us to sit here and write oh you're
you're gonna hate me because i'm an
anti-man and that's fine
it's very easy it's a complicated [ __ ]
it's easy to write off men to be like
well they like their [ __ ] animals no
they're they're human humans
they can control their feet well i don't
i don't advocate cheating i've never
advocated i don't think it's cool to
cheat but what i'm saying is like i
think you have some level of
responsibility as a wife to have sex
with your husband i understand like so
if you haven't done it in like two or
three years like i think i would
understand if he left or told you he was
going to sleep
that's a part of being in a relationship
that's part of being in a relationship
yeah two or three years that's different
than like if you go through like two or
three months where you're not having sex
okay yeah yeah
not only that how complicated is the
relationship or marriage for that person
to not want to be sexually active that's
the thing like what is he doing that's
making her uncomfortable have you ever
seen a couple where the girl feels like
she's settled and she's not really into
him but she just wants like kids you
never seen that that that is her [ __ ]
i've seen that no it's her fault
but i'm saying
but i'm saying a lot of times the guy
doesn't know that
he doesn't know like
who communicates
he couldn't blame him for that if he was
to step out that's what that's what i'm
saying yeah yeah relax as well like he
can't expect that communication from my
head hurts he's not delivering that
himself like that's where there's a
two-way
i'm with you i don't advocate cheating
but i would understand if he wanted to
get a divorce on the grounds he hasn't
had sex in three years if he vocalized
that divorce and that separation issues
and then cool down his thing
fair enough yeah if he was to go be
petty and be like cool i haven't got
anything for my wife you might not even
know the reason i say she got abused or
kidnapped or something
she didn't feel comfortable to tell you
look at her a certain way what is
understanding but why don't you jump to
the communications
yeah definitely but it's still lack of
communication on his part like he can
never say he was in the right emotional
world
no i'm with you i don't agree with
cheating like i'm never going to
advocate for cheating i don't think it's
cool to cheat
but i understand like where men are
coming from when they haven't like
because they're all that happens a lot
maybe getting [ __ ] and still go ahead
go ahead also i think it's important to
know like in the day and age we're in
there's temptation everything everywhere
let me tell you if you have a fine man
or a fine woman there are people waiting
waiting
patiently waiting so it's like you kind
of do like you know okay also like i'm
not saying women aren't but men are a
lot more like visual yeah women we're a
lot more internal emotional what are you
doing for me like like an exchange of
like goods almost like what are you
doing that kind of turns us off yeah the
things you can like almost give us in a
way but like men are like they'll see
something and they want it and they're
like oh sparkly like
well they're more they're more visual
and also sex doesn't as like like it's
it's not as much to them as it is to us
as a woman i'm not going to get a dick
pic and be like
oh my god
but he's a man like he's going to get a
picture of a kid
and he's going to be like i need to [ __ ]
this [ __ ] right now so it's
like a woman
you have to kind of be aware of that
like [ __ ] are lurking yeah so you've
got to you have to say
we can hold our own i feel like they
should hold their own issues it's about
if what you want like if you really want
this say i'm a man i've got my partner
if i want my man enough
no other guy will tell me like i could
maybe look at a ground block oh yeah
you'll find this one don't mean i want
you though essentially or you can just
like you guys
but i might think yeah you're attractive
i could even think just as attractive
doesn't mean i
want her yeah and i could have a man
well do you think cheating
do you think do you think cheating is
different for men and women
really
um the principle is the principle no no
we're not we're not talking about we're
not talking about the principle though
so what i'm saying cheating is different
for men and women i think men can have
sex with someone they don't even like
and never want to see again we're girls
i could
like you know what i'm saying like i've
been in space in my life where i don't
even need to like
yeah do you do you feel like that's the
norm because i don't feel like that's
what is the norm
who defines that norm i mean statistics
and like like i mean like statistics
general data anecdotal like you could
take i was going to say that men are
very much heat of the moment type of
cheaters
and when it comes to women it sometimes
can be more on the emotional side
because when you have a partner that you
love dearly but you feel like you're not
getting enough from them emotionally you
might try to find that out elsewhere and
that becomes a problem and that's why
oftentimes men feel like it's worse when
girls cheat because they're like damn
that's because it's emotionally
available okay and like you know my
girls because because
because
women
from what i've seen tend to cheat up so
like if they're cheating it's like
there's
we were even saying earlier like oh we
have to be worried about the ugly girl
like you know you know because men will
sleep with like goddamn anything but
like women like if you're cheating from
what i've seen like usually the guy that
they're cheating with has something the
partner doesn't have where the girl if
he cheats it's like she'll have nothing
yeah
yeah
[Music]
so
in my experience it was like mentally i
was done like i didn't want to be with
you [ __ ] anymore like i was
no i'm so serious like i was like so
done and like it just he wouldn't leave
me alone and i kept trying to break up
with him the nice way and then it was
like i felt stuck
it for certain reasons and then i would
just like mentally i was done i cheated
and i was like i don't care anymore
because you hurt me in so many ways
emotionally that's brought me to this
point where
i don't care and like now
looking back yes i regret those actions
because that's not right i could have
just put my foot down and not been a
weak [ __ ] and then like i don't want to
be with you which i actually did do and
he just like would tell me no
don't know how the [ __ ] that was
probably like my therapist told me i was
bipolar and i told her no
but you know like i feel like
for me personally not speaking for all
women but it was like uh i didn't care
like because i was done i left the
relationship mentally way before i
cheated
i feel like some women when they do
cheat it's not like
initially or like when they
it's not the intention yeah it'll be
like
build up so they'll start talking to
somebody they'll be they'll be fed
emotionally and then it gets to that
point where it's like okay i'm gonna
have sex with you and i feel like not
all women but i feel like that emotional
like
boundary is like set and then they like
keep building and then it ends up that's
right that's why i watch the male
friends
that are trifling like yeah they just go
out and do whatever they just pull up to
the club and they're like all right i'm
taking you off and then the other half
are just like i'm not getting what i
need yeah i need i need to be fed
somewhere else okay